to rescue operations underway in Greece
after two separate boats carrying
suspected migrants sank off the coast of
two islands more than 80 people are
still missing at least 15 have confirmed
to have died
30 rescued off the island of kithra with
80 still missing and near the Island of
Lesbos 15 bodies found after dinghy
carrying around 40 people sank there
let's get more uh should we and joining
us as you can see is Adam hi Adam what
more do we know
yeah I think the first thing to say is
that these appear to be just two
separate incidents there's no link
between them it's just a pretty Grim
coincidence that they happen on on the
same night I suspect because the weather
was difficult winds uh going at about 45
miles an hour now this is a a familiar
route of people migrants trying to get
into Greece going from Turkey but this
is kythera this is the island where the
bigger the boat we think it's a Sailing
Boat that hit the Rocks next to kithra
and as you can see there people on board
that that boat and you can you can see
dark Inky Blackness of night scrambling
towards the rocks and being pulled up on
ropes by locals and and by some
officials this is a really rudimentary
Rescue of people who are stranded as you
can see from that man there wearing the
lightest most flimsiest of clothes and
on board a Sailing Boat that was
carrying around a hundred people and ran
aground off a place called diaf kutti on
the east of the island now we are
grasping for any kind of reliable
numbers it is thought
that about a hundred people were on that
boat 30 at the last message we have from
officials have been rescued there are
completely unconfirmed reports from from
other local media that the number of
people accounted for is actually
significantly higher than that but at
the moment getting reliable information
out of uh out of kithra and out of
Lesbos is proving challenging the other
incidents on Lesbos involved a smaller
craft a dinghy that was carrying around
40 people we are told that 15 bodies
have been recovered so far I think in
their background in in that image you
can get an idea that the the sea was
rough that this was a very very
difficult uh rescue as I said
unconnected incidents but this is a very
familiar migrant route for people trying
to get from Turkey onto these Greek
Islands and then get into the European
Union at the moment the death toll
remains very difficult to calculate 15
dead we know in lesbos but of course at
the moment we wait for more reliable
figures of how many have been rescued
and of course how many others have
perished